managing the communication between
microservices in your application can be
a challenging task especially as your
application scales in size and
complexity
an event-based architecture and Google
Cloud managed services for application
integration can help you address the
complexity
in the service orchestration and
choreography on Google Cloud course
learn how the orchestration and
choreography patterns can be used to
coordinate service communication and how
four managed Services provided by Google
Cloud can streamline the process
hi my name is Mike and I'm a technical
curriculum developer here at Google
Cloud this course introduces you to the
orchestration and choreography patterns
and the services in Google Cloud used to
coordinate microservices workflows event
Arc Cloud tasks and Cloud scheduler
this content is for application
developers Architects and Cloud
Engineers who want to build applications
with microservices through a series of
video lectures quizzes and Hands-On Labs
you get an introduction to microservices
event driven applications and the use of
service choreography and orchestration
in Google Cloud
you learn how to describe the benefits
and challenges of microservices-based
architectures and the advantages of
event-driven applications
in addition you learn to identify the
strengths of orchestration in
choreography
and use workflows event Arc Cloud tasks
and Cloud scheduler to coordinate a
microservices application on Google
Cloud
let's get started